senator Kirsten Gillibrand has announced
tonight that she is dropping out of the
2020 presidential race but after more
than eight incredible months I'm ending
my presidential campaign
I know this isn't the results we wanted
we wanted to win this race but it's
important to know when it's not your
time and to know how you can best serve
your community and country I believe I
can best serve by helping to unite us to
beat Donald Trump in 2020 so under
normal circumstances that might qualify
as a Fox News Alert but in the case of
Gillibrand she does not deserve it not
only did she ever poll above the margin
of error ever
she was looking back perhaps the worst
candidate ever to run from any party in
the history of this country
Gillibrand in fact represented the worst
trends of the modern left all in one
package
for starters she's an utter phony she
cares only about accumulating power for
herself as a congresswoman in New York
she supported gun rights and fiscal
discipline she said she wanted to secure
southern border then almost immediately
after being handed Hillary Clinton's
Senate seat
Gillibrand dreamed of war more so she
lurched far to the left unvirtuous every
issue but it wasn't just that because
she cared only about power
Gillibrand was happy to be friends with
Bill Clinton and Harvey Weinstein when
they were useful to her no matter what
she may have known about them no matter
what everyone else knew about them but
then later when it was politically
expedient she denounced them but only
once she was certain they wouldn't be
useful anymore but she didn't stop there
she also remember led the effort to push
Al Franken out of the United States
Senate though there was no proof he'd
done anything wrong far be it for us to
defend Al Franken but it was that unfair
but that's Kirsten Gillibrand in a
nutshell a pampered hypocrite with no
scruples happy to lecture you about your
failings and your privilege watch this
the first thing that I'm going to do
when I'm president is I'm going to
Clorox The Oval Office we need to pass a
green new deal this should be our
nation's moonshot if you don't take
global climate change seriously
you don't care about the world in the
country you don't care about people as
president the United States I wouldn't
use the detention system at all we would
be delighted to take refugee families
into cities like Buffalo and Syracuse
and Rochester is 15 years old and smokes
pot he smokes pot just as much as the
black boy his neighborhood and the
Latino boy in his neighborhood but that
black and brown boy is four times more
likely to be arrested that's
institutional racism your son will
likely not have to deal with that
because he is white self-righteous dumb
yeah that's par for the course here in
Washington but the last clip shows what
Gillibrand stands apart that was
Gillibrand united state senator
lecturing a mother in youngstown ohio
ever been to Youngstown Ohio I've been
in the honing Valley Gillian was telling
her how no matter how much Washington
abandons her and her entire region to
unemployment and drug addiction suicide
and diabetes actually that woman should
be ashamed of her white privilege that's
Kirsten Gillibrand in one clip really
the worst candidate ever good riddance
Kirsten Gillibrand Seth Barron is
associated at City Journal and he joins
us tonight said you know you hate to
pile on it takes courage to run for
office I sympathize with candidates when
they get out because it's it's painful
it stings it's humiliating but in the
case of Kirsten Gillibrand it can't come
a moment too soon
I can't think of someone more false
nastier crueler more self-centered
dumber can you well yeah I mean mayor de
Blasio is kind of a Kirsten Gillibrand
has run a she's a complete hypocrite as
you said she was a Blue Dog Democrat she
got high ratings from the NRA and then
when she became senator she said that
she was embarrassed of her ninety-eight
percent white home district you know all
these bones and she was glad to embrace
the you know the the woke philosophy of
the new left but remember she was a her
senatorial seat was essentially
orchestrated by her close ally former
Republican senator al D'Amato
so she's very much just a an opportunist
if you'll recall she made a big deal out
of going on and dropping f-bombs about
Trump every 10 minutes yeah she's she's
she's pretty she's pretty egregious I
would say but I guess I guess what
bothers me is not and I just want to put
a finer point on it because Washington's
full of phony people I mean that's
against but it's politics so there's
there's some falseness right there's
posters in television don't to be
self-righteous about it she's mean
that's what I don't like about her she's
cruel to lecture that woman in
Youngstown Ohio of all places about her
privilege we shoulda treated Al Franken
who I don't like and don't agree with I
don't like Al Franken at all but she was
so mean to him yeah that's outrageous
and that she said she would be the
emissary for white women she would go
and explain to them why their sons were
spared
police brutality because of their white
privilege so essentially she campaigned
on the message that elect me and I'll
make sure your sons get shot was there
anybody in the United States Senate in
democratic politics any large group of
voters was anybody ever for this
candidacy
I don't think so apparently even her
staff was kind of embarrassed and
chagrin that she was keeping this up you
know I have to say I did not think that
she would drop out before mayor de
Blasio yeah it seemed like she had more
of a claim to or more of a path but you
know I guess reality intruded yeah I
mean I think you know here I've been
beating up on her but I do think she's
sharper than mayor de Blasio enough
that's saying too much really quick can
it will she keep her Senate seat I guess
in a one-party state like New York you
can you can stay forever in the Senate
no matter even if you're Kirsten
Gillibrand well people have said that
you know she could be susceptible to a
challenge from Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
and that may be in the cards for her so
I would support a Kazuya Cortes over
Kirsten Gillibrand any day of the week
you may have something there
yeah that been great to see you thank
you